Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar
Today MIT ranks as one of the top universities in the world.
Nearly 150 years ago, this question appeared on its admissions exam.
"The perpendicular dropped from the vertex of the right angle upon the hypotenuse
divides it into two segments of 9 and 16 feet respectively.
Find the lengths of the perpendicular, and the two legs of the triangle."
Give this problem a try. And when you're ready, keep watching the video for the solution.
We'll get started by drawing a diagram. We have a right triangle.
We're going to draw a perpendicular from the vertex of the right angle to the hypotenuse.
This divides the hypotenuse into two segments of 9 and 16 feet.
We need to find the lengths of the perpendicular and the two legs of the triangle.
The perpendicular to the hypotenuse of a right triangle creates a special set of triangles.
The green triangle here and the blue triangle here are similar triangles.
This means the ratio of their lengths and angles are the same.
In particular, the length of the shorter leg of the green triangle to its longer leg will be the same ratio as the
length of the shorter leg of the blue triangle to its longer leg.
So we can set the ratio of the shorter leg to the longer leg of each triangle equal to each other.
In the green triangle, we have 9 divided by p. And in the blue triangle we have p divided by 16
We can cross multiply these fractions to get p-squared is equal to 9 times 16 which equals 144
This means p is equal to the positive square root of 144 which is 12
So we've solved for one part of the problem that the perpendicular has the length of 12
We now need to solve for the two legs of the triangle
Notice that each leg of a triangle is equal to the hypotenuse of one of these smaller triangles
We could use the Pythagorean theorem to figure out the legs
In the green triangle,
the length of the hypotenuse would be the square root of the sum of the squares of the legs of the green triangle.
And the same thing is true in the blue triangle
But we don't need to go through these calculations if we notice one more thing.
In each of these triangles the ratio of the shorter leg to the longer leg is 3:4
So each of these smaller triangles is a scaled up version of the 3 4 5 right triangle
So we can solve for the hypotenuse by scaling appropriately
The green triangle has lengths which are three times that of a 3 4 5 right triangle
Which means its hypotenuse has to be 3 times 5 which is 15
Similarly the blue triangle is
scaled up 4 times a 3 4 5 right triangle
so its hypotenuse will be 4 times 5 which is equal to 20.
And that's the solution
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video please subscribe to my channel
I make videos on math and game theory. You can catch me on my blog Mind Your Decisions
Which you can follow on Facebook google+ and patreon. You can catch me on social media @preshtalwalkar
And if you liked this video, please check out my books. There are links in the video description.